JOANNE STUBBE: If you look
at the vitamin bottle,
you have all these vitamins
you eat, like, what
do they call them?
Biotin, riboflavin, pyridoxal.
So all of those small, organic
molecules, and they all
have chemical reactivity and
they interact with the protein
and allow the protein to do
chemistry that can't normally
be carried out by just the amino
acid side chains of the protein
in the active site
of the enzyme.
So the vitamins you
eat are not actually
what's interacting
with the protein,
they need to be modified.
So they are the
precursors to what
are called co-factors
that, again,
expand the repertoire of what's
found in enzymatic systems.
So you have a whole bunch
of organic co-factors
that actually can be
made spontaneously.
If you throw in some simple
molecules like cyanide
and stuff, these things
all self-assemble,
so they're all from
the primordial soup.
And in fact, many
of these vitamins
can do chemistry without
any enzyme at all.
But they can't do
it specifically.
And they can't do it rapidly.
So we have all these
organic molecules
that can self-assemble
that expand the repertoire,
but if you look at a vitamin
bottle, you will see minerals.
And that's one thing that I
think most biochemistry courses
don't talk about, is metals.
And it's now proposed
that between 35% and 50%
of all the proteins in
our body have metals that
are essential for function.
And so these minerals that you
eat, iron or zinc or calcium,
all play a central role,
again, in expanding.
They all help in many
cases facilitate chemical
transformations,
and in the way we
can understand by understanding
basic chemical principles.
So the vitamin
bottle, we come back
to over and over again through
the course of the semester,
because all the enzymes
in metabolic pathways
have different kinds of
co-factors that are required
to make the enzymes function.